[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous et on attend vos points de vue
ce soir sur les dernières déclarations
de jérôme salomon le directeur général
de la santé écarte toute idée de
confinement pour la région ile-de-france
alors est-ce que c'est raisonnable at il
tort on en débat avec vous on est dans
vos commentaires vos questions et on en
débat ce soir avec béatrice giblin
bonsoir béatrice et on rappelle que vous
êtes entre autres universitaires
rédactrice en chef de la revue hérodote
et le dernier numéro est consacré à
l'afrique médiane mais on sait qu'à
partir de jeudi
on a on vient d'apprendre que à partir
de jeudi à paris un nouveau numéro sur
le maghreb
vous regarderez nous en parler avec vous
avec nous avec six mois' et bonsoir
alexis directeur des rédactions du
figaro on reviendra ensemble sur un
autre dossier brûlant ce soir le rôle de
l'unef dans les injures contre deux
profs de sciences po grenoble qui ont
été traités de fascistes et
d'islamophobe leurs noms jetés en pâture
est inscrit sur les murs de la fac à
l'entrée de l'établissement
mais d'abord donc le confinement qui est
prolongé pour trois week-ends dans la
région de dunkerque alors à paris en ile
de france les données montrent une
hausse notamment des hospitalisations et
des patients en réanimation alors la
région-capitale va-t-elle connaître le
même sort que nice il ya quelques
semaines que dunkerque
réponse ce matin du directeur général de
la santé jérôme salomon le confinement
de l'île de france n'est pas d'actualité
parce que cette mesure de dernier
recours serait proposé au gouvernement
et au chef de l'état si nous avions
l'impression que l'hôpital ne pouvait
pas tenir et que nous ne lisons nous
avions nous étions en face d'un risque
majeur de ne pouvoir accueillir les
malades graves à l'hôpital
donc nous sommes en saturation mais nous
tenons nous sommes en très forte tension
nous libérons délit nous n'y verrons
beaucoup de l'île des centaines de lits
et nous suivons la situation jour après
jour alors sur le site du figaro on vous
pose la question après vous vous
approuvez vous le choix exprimé par
jérôme seulement je vais arriver de ne
par confiner l'île de france
béatrice quel est votre point de vue sur
se met à écouter
j'ai regardé un peu les chiffres sur le
site qui est qu'ovide tracker qui est un
site très très très bien fait qui
al'avantage de lycéens peu on n'est pas
au jour par jour
et puis j'ai voulu aller regarder les
chiffres de cette dernière semaine par
rapport aux chiffres d'il ya un an
voilà et ça donne quand même des choses
très intéressantes parce que bon en
avril 2020 je sais bien qu'on est en
mars mais on était à 13000
hospitalisation en ile de france
on est aujourd'hui à 5500 donc on a
quand même un seuil important le passage
aux urgences j'ai trouvé que c'était
intéressant ça au 31 mars de l'année
dernière c'était quatre mille par jour
cette fois ci c'est 720 donc on est un
nom jeudi 31 mars étaient 4000 et
s'adonner 720 hospitalisation on est au
4 mars à 200 passages aux urgences et on
est à 140 hospitalisation donc on voit
bien qu'on n'est pas dans la même
configuration bien évidemment de celle
du premier confinement ni même de celle
du deuxième qui n'a pas été aussi forte
mais tu es quand même beaucoup plus
forte que ce qu'on à pau pour l'instant
donc je crois que si le taux d'incidence
est en moyenne nationale un peu plus de
deux cents il est à 300 à paris c'est
vrai il est à plus de 400 en seine saint
denis c'est vrai mais il était à 9 cents
à dunkerque
donc on est quand même sur des chiffres
tout à fait différent donc moi je pense
que
on a raison pour l'instant de ne pas
continuer bon si on dit toujours ça la
course de vitesse on se rend compte
quand même que le nombre de décès chez
les gens très âgés baisse maintenant
très régulièrement grâce au vaccin
voilà alors ceux qui vraiment moi me
stupéfie et suscite vraiment une
interrogation c'est comment se fait-il
que 30 % seulement du personnel soignant
soit vexé
ok on va peut-être revenir mais sur
cette décision donc enfin en tous les
cas cette ses déclarations pendant que
je sais lui n'attend et baptiste qui
sont en train de me rejoindre qui
commentent de jérôme salomon peut-être
car il ya un autre chiffre
il ya mille personnes environ un peu un
peu moins de 1000 sont en réanimation
pour 1700 places on risque pas la
saturation rapidement comme jérôme
simplement disais est ce pas ta qu'il ya
quand même eu une tension quand même
pour une fois que jérôme seulement nous
dit pas qu'il faut confiné on va pas
être plus l aumône istres est allemand
d'habitude il faut voir le scénario
d'habitude c'est à l'orangé avoir
seulement dit il faut il faut confiné
absolument confiné l'aveyron qui dit on
va à confiner yakassé qu'il y aura sans
doute confiné et mâcon gagner non on va
pas confiné bon là même salomon dit
qu'on va pas confiné donc d'abord c'est
qu'on va pas confiné de tant mieux et
c'est pas les chiens rien à dire aux
chefs de projets qui sont remarquables
c'est un vrai travail d' enquête que
vous avez fait ça me paraît le bon sens
même tout ce qui peut permettre
évidemment que si un jour on est obligé
on le fera mais d'abord c'est pas du
tout sûr que non on sent bien qu'il ya
deux dynamiques qui sont il ya la
dynamique des vaccins il ya même trois
amicales et des mimiques des vaccins qui
commence à produire ses effets notamment
chez les personnes âgées
et du coup il ya moins de gens dans les
urgences moins de gens dans l'hôpital
heures après l'épidémie peut qu'une se
répondent mais si elles touchent moi des
gens moins vieux qui vont donc moins
l'hôpital qui t'ont crise moins de
mourir va on construit une immunité
comme ça une immunité collective et donc
l'effet cumulé de l'immunité collective
et 2 et 2
et de la vaccination peut espérons-le
mais pour l'instant ça a l'air plutôt de
marché compenser l'effet éventuel
éventuel parce qu'en plus on n'est pas
absolument sûr d'accélération du ovarian
pas tant que ça marche ça marche c'est
pour l'instant franchement je vois pas
pourquoi il faudrait il faudrait être
confiné à l'instant vous disiez vous ne
comprenez pas pourquoi seulement 13% des
personnels de santé alors aussi c'est
une moyenne
il est très très élevé chez les aides
soignants il les brêmois chez les
médecins
donc quand on dit remboursant il faut
regarder les choses un peu plus tard peu
plus précisément mais même le personnel
des ehpad ne se fait pas vacciner de
façon massive
je trouve que c'est quand même et une
interrogation alors qui vient peut-être
tout discours qui a eu au départ on
n'est pas sur les effets secondaires
enfin les effets secondaires du vaccin
il y en a toujours eu des effets
secondaires designs les comprimés
exactement bon donc je sais pour moi une
interrogation de la situation française
parce que ça date pas de vue de la
corrida
ils se font pas vacciner non plus pour
la grippe non les hôpitaux et on n'a pas
l'équivalent dans d'autres pays
européens j'ai commencé à regarder ça on
n'a pas ça au royaume uni on n'a pas ça
en allemagne on n'a pas ça aux pays bas
on passa en italie qu'est ce qui fait
qu'on ait cette culture que très
exactement
c'est très étonnant c'est au pays de
pasteur quand même mais on a quand même
été parmi les derniers à mettre en place
avec six nations à la fin du 19e 1 les
marques l'avait fait tous les autres
l'avait fait et avec un lobby médical à
l'époque qui était très senti vexé et je
trouve que là bas on on manque
véritablement de culture de santé
publique
j'ai l'impression de prévention et de
santé publique
votre venue dire justement ce centre va
c'est un peu à l'aller c'est évidemment
c'est un vrai sujet c'est vrai qu'on ne
n'arrive pas à comprendre alors après la
conclusion enfin en plus c'est une
double peine parce que comme on a dit et
heureusement on ne craint de revenir
qu'il fallait à tout prix préserver les
vaccins personnel soignant et que le
pasteur ou le pass vassilissa pour une
grande partie de pas et c'est vrai que
les médecins en gros sont séduits 70 que
les infirmières s'est lui-même sa cote
baisser mais ce qu'on dit sud accord
après alors je ne défends pas mais après
il ya pas déjà de tous les jeunes qui 18
mois je risque rien oui mais je ne
défends pas je dis juste et plus après
les aides soignants effectivement qui
sont traversés mais je voyais récemment
un chef de service qui dit mais moi
j'aime les aides soignantes y en a qui
disent nous on veut pas vacciner parce
que des nanoparticules qui sont mis en
place par les américains pour nous trace
etc
en même temps c'est pas comme
enseignants ne sont pas c'est pas un
milieu qui est absolument étranger aux
prions dieu et c'est des gens comme tout
le monde et les mêmes sottises qui passe
dans la tête des gens se retrouvent de
chez les fai chez les ciel et des
soignants et donc nous et j'ajoute que
donc
on commet plus notre processus très
administrative très bureaucratique
français quo c'est-à-dire tant que tous
les soignants ne seront pas vaccinés on
ne vaccinera pas les autres comme sépare
du trois semaines à bloquer tout un tas
de vaccins quand on entend ça y est on a
compris enfin compris oui alors après
maintenant font quoi y arriver à le
faire les attendait 100 mille doses
réservé aux médecins les médecins venus
les chercher mais là encore certes sous
les eaux d'abord pendant plusieurs
semaines on voulait pas leur randonnée
mais ils ont tellement il faut comme
voir le timing après on leur a dit alain
dit vous allez pouvoir
sauf que quand on est médecin et qu'on
veut organiser ça on n'y va pas le mardi
chercher les trucs il faut appeler ses
patients prendre les rendez vous calé
dix rendez-vous de suite maintenant
parce que sinon si on prend une
bouteille et que la stratégie casseurs à
frère mais pour l'instant la seconde
sont stockés aujourd'hui chez les jets
les
chez les pharmaciens s'est passé pas de
files heures parce qu'il faut qu'ils
soient moins 62
en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est même ce
système on enfin oddo c'est vrai que les
médecins ont entraîné mais c'est parce
qu'aussi pendant pendant des semaines on
n'a pas voulu leur donner puisque on
disait c'est que dans l'est dans les
ehpad et c'est uniquement pour le
personnage et puis tout à coup
et enfin il ya une espèce de climat
d'improvisation de 2,2 au change de
pilote en est le truc qui consiste à
dire alors maintenant on va le retirer
au médecin pour le donner aux
pharmaciens et puis on dit ah oui mais
entre temps va quand même livré les
médecins que la semaine prochaine on
dirait qu'il faut livrer les médecins
donc on va beaucoup bouclé le robinet
des pharmaciens je dis juste que c'est
pas gérer il ya quand même un problème
de logistique de deux logiques des
tuyaux mais néanmoins que vous ayez
quand même un nombre de médecins de
médecine générale je te qui ne soit pas
la lutte s'organise émission quand même
plusieurs bons quand ils veulent
s'organiser après on refonde les accents
celle des autres notamment chez les
femmes et chez les pourquoi parce qu'il
y en avait cinq cent mille qui était pas
utilisé et qu'ils avaient commandés
disent que quand ils demandent elles ne
sont pas datées scalisi l'ont déjà
utilisé les moyens comme un système
quand on voit d'ailleurs j'aime moi ces
prix trop cher une ciné concert d'hiver
ont germé alors oui on a en fait on a
d'une part la pénurie européenne ckia
pas au total assez de vaccins est ce que
l'europe c'est mal débrouillé et puis
passionne ils sont annoncés début un
nombre de livraisons que les
laboratoires nationaux
on n'a pas su les commandes s'est quand
même fait frappant de voir qu'en europe
les deux pays qui s'en tire le mieux
c'est le rhume unis et la serbie qui ne
sont pas dans l'union européenne
c'est à se demander si on a une raison
je pense que nos deux confié à l'union
européenne le soin de la politique de
santé choses à l'image est heureusement
qu'on l'a fait hier bal royal s'appelle
my only bébés chirac août et quand on
voit c'est ce que dit le royaume mais
non ce qui permet au royaume uni de
l'avoir c'est quand même lastras zeneca
qu'ils ont pas que mais essentiellement
non ils l'ont quand même ils l'ont
qu'ils ont quand même vacciné avant même
d'avoir tout lé et bien voyons des
résultats et parce que eh bien parce
qu'on n'a pas voulu non mais on ne
rigole parce que justement
il ya une telle méfiance mais il est mon
médecin ou votre père simplement à la
méfiance vous voulez attribuer est-ce
qu'on peut pas attribuer également la
lourdeur administrative et je veux bien
qu'on l'attribué la lourdeur
administrative passée au lieu dit c'est
un ensemble de choses c'est d'abord très
longtemps en amont ils ont commencé à
investir à mettre de l'argent débloqué
de l'argent
oui c'est un risque majeur gens et on
n'a pas voulu prendre ce riz et l'europe
ne veut pas prendre ce risque donc on
n'a pas mis l'argent on n'a pas investi
résultat tout est comme souvent dans ces
entreprises françaises et d'entreprises
françaises qui sont du coup aller
chercher ou au royaume uni ou aux états
unis les américains l'état fédéral a
débloqué d'argent non l'a pas fait donc
on a deux on n'a pas débloqué d'argent
le au royaume uni ils ont commencé très
en amont à nos mères responsable de la
vaccination mais beaucoup plus tôt qu'au
départ on était dans une situation fait
qu'ils venaient d'arriver clairement
combien de man le gars qu'on a nommé
récemment des chercheurs
après a expliqué qu'il n'était pas
spécialiste de logistique oui mais après
faut passer avec la musique marche parce
qu'on pouvait certes avant vous ont pas
faire que ça ils ont confié à l'armée
le soin d'organiser oui mais nous on a
confié aux rs balle et le reste m de la
santé l'armée a même dit c'est mon
boulot c'est pour moi de faire ça
maintenant
mais c'est à la limite on pouvait lire
vous pouvez demander on a des
logisticiens de l'eau alors que renault
minimes et se demander à des à des
bénévoles de participer à la formation
pour distribuer les vaccins
ils ont mis en place des vaccinodromes
chose qu'on a refusé on a fait en
alexander
qu'est ce que voulez qu'on fasse un maxi
notre souci n'est pas de ces avancées
sont installés les anglais ils avaient
les lieux bah ouais franchement quand je
vois la situation qu'ils ont eue dans
leurs hôpitaux quand je vois le nombre
de morts qu'ils ont eue quand on voit
qu'ils ont été totalement débordée du
tant mieux si maintenant ça marche pour
la vaccination
bah ils ont été consignés compagnies
viennent d'être de confinés pendant
combien de temps fait trois mois de
confinement attendait les élèves ont
repris l'école louise magnan à ce qu ils
ont fait d'autres choix est bien mais le
mal le masque est tout d'abord à moi
même et non à londres alors on a
longtemps mais ce n'est pas obligatoire
mais a limité les petites qu'ils aient
fait des erreurs
je défends pas boris johnson il en a
fait l'un mais ils en ont tiré les
conséquences ils ont réagi comme des
britanniques dans l'adversité ils se
sont mobilisés ils ont fait des choix
courageux ils ont organisé et
aujourd'hui ils sont le oui mais ils ont
accédé beaucoup n'ont pas accès normal
aux biens des gens non mais en tout cas
pour les personnes âgées sont voisines
et les jeunes sont très largement
wechsel maintenant on va regarder
l'évolution du nombre de maires
regardez regardez non mais faut regarder
du couple quand même c'est pas bien on
ne voulait pas reconnaître les gens on
se comprend pas non mais il n'est pas
question de passer des fêtes que les
légendes les vaccine bien mais les
serbes aussi vaccinés oui il ya plein de
vie qui vaccinent mieux que nous ne
sommes pas des oui bien sûr et je suis
on me la fait tous tel règlement
donc il faut pas dire qu'on a tout bien
faire mais je ne me fais je ne dis pas
qu'on a tous dont je ne dis pas qu'on a
dans le fait qu'on ait moins confiné que
d'autres et que les trois mois que
viennent de subir les britanniques
moi je regrette je préfère marquer un
deuxième commandement on may à calais
qui a été beaucoup québec beaucoup plus
haut oui il est grand temps qu'on était
confiné d'un club dont il n'était pas
considéré saison confiné à la fin de
notre deuxième confinement et le ce
qu'elle appelle confinement eux c'est
pendant 40 ans de ne pas porter de
masque
c'était très tard les masques rubens
était peut-être pas une très bonne idée
une bonne idée mais ne pourra pas dire à
la blague que ils ont très fortement
confinées à la maison quand même confiné
puisque les magasins étaient fermés
puisque les gamins elle n'est pas à
l'école et qu'on était obligé au
télétravail
si ça ressemble pas et qu'on a pu et
c'est après qu'on a pu descendre les
prix sont accablants mais si on n'a pas
tout ça je vois pas comment vous pouvez
ne pas blesser un confinement
les chiffres là vous déplacez le sujet
mais non qu'est ce que va nous dire que
ce n'était pas vrai confinement recours
à le voir ça le sujet aujourd'hui c'est
le vaccin eh bien ils ont beaucoup plus
de max 1 et vaccine ils ont vacciné une
dose il s 12 semaines voilà il parle
pour qu'on l'a pas fait mais parce que
nous avons un comment un milieu médical
qui est un milieu médical qui a
extrêmement peur est d'accord qui a
extrêmement peur
regardez moi on est médecin s'opposer à
ce que les pharmaciens maxime pour la
grippe mais bien sûr je puisse que l'on
était un consensus
je propose de donner à quel la parole
aux internautes
qui suivent ce débat passionné et
passionnant dont on attend 770 puisque
la question a été posée justement sur le
confinement en ile de france les
chiffres et vol et évolue pareillement
qu'on confie 90 toutes les statistiques
mondiales le démontre ça c'est un autre
un autre débat
nicole nous dit c'est contradictoire ils
sont sous tension il ne confirme pas
mais il ordonne de déprogrammer 4 40%
des opérations ça c'est intéressant
c'est il ya toujours quand même ce
processus process ce procédé qui
consiste à avoir à avoir peur en
préventif ben oui c'est se dire c'est
qu'une fois que vous mesurez il faut
essayer d'avoir toujours une petite
marche de mai d'avocats où effectivement
par exemple ce fameux varié en anglais
axel raix il est déjà majoritaire et si
les prend et encore plus espace on aura
beaucoup de gens accueillir donc en
prévision on des programmes mais cette
fois ci ils ont précisé que des progrès
mais pas ce qui relevait des concerts
dire qu'on va faire des choix dans la
déprogrammation on va peut-être des
programmes et je sais pas la hanche
qu'on doit changer ou autre chose mais
ce qui sera cardiaque esquissera
cancéreux sera pas déprogrammé dire
qu'on apprend aussi et ce qui s'est
passé au premier confinement et les
conséquences que ça a pu avoir
on fait un sans doute beaucoup plus
attention enfin je le pense de façon à
ce qu'on retrouve pas de même situation
et nous ne sommes pas dans la même
situation avec les chiffres que j'ai
donné dans la crise tels que nous étions
mois d'avril de l'année dernière ce sont
sur le nombre de lits c'est ça aussi qui
est invraisemblable c'est qu'en un an on
n'ait pas augmenté le nombre de
compétiteurs on ne l'a pas augmenté il
semble même que les diminuer parce que
sans de soignants et de son parti
veulent plus
quand le nombre de lits reste le même
mais que le nombre de personnes pouvant
les gérer lui a dit a diminué mais c'est
invraisemblable mais on nous a dit on
peut pas faire de lien en deux mois ok
on nous a dit on peut pas faire de
nouveaux lits en six mois ok maintenant
on peut pas faire de lien on ne pourra
jamais faire de nouveau les c'est un
vrai sens vrai que si on forme des gens
ça demande ça demandera sans se demande
à voir les chiffres sous mais pas
forcément cause mais j'aimerais quand
même des secours sur la saturation de
qui me semble aberrant 2ème de prétendre
qu'on augmente et vous avez-vous sais
pas si vous je ne sais pas si cette
information n'a pu être vérifiée ou pas
des du personnel soignant je pense que
cette argenteuil pour ne pas se faire
vacciner a pris un mois de congé sans
solde qui sont plusieurs
je suis atterré bon ce sera un bon sujet
de vérifier ça serait un bon sujet de
vérification sont sinon mais je le mets
comme ça je ne la firme pas après tout
les problèmes aujourd'hui ne viennent
pas du jeu je le regarde comme vous que
du problème que les phenom ii se
vaccinent pas c'est pas non plus le nom
économiste a traduit à mon avis ce même
vous pensiez la question mais pourquoi
on n'a pas fait parce qu'on a peur parce
qu'on prend alors vaccine au royaume uni
pour 100 habitants
33 france 5 rendez vous ça vous fait pas
monter aux dires de près tats-unis états
unis mais 17 mai vous rendez compte
oui je sais comment on peut dire que
elle comparaît aussi à ce moment là avec
l'allemagne compagnie du peuple un tout
petit peu bah oui parce que bien oui
l'italie c'est mieux que nous l'espagne
c'est mieux que nous oui pas beaucoup
mais va mieux mais oui mais quand même
mais parce qu'on a choisi par des vieux
épaté et pas de vacciner sans s'en sont
souvenus je pense que mon assiette
d'accord si on avait actionné tout le
monde s'en faire le choix on serait
peut-être aux mêmes chiffres on a décidé
de vacciner les personnes âgées en ehpad
pour faire baisser le nombre de morts
comparons les noms on a gardé le même
vaccin vous deviez vous même en stoppeur
des semaines
mais peut-être qu'on part en langue de
mort et même vacciné mais ça sera
peut-être un autre débat on garde quand
même les gens en ehpad qui ne peuvent
pas encore sortir
isabelle nous disons que parlant de
jérôme salle où mon c'était lui le point
de départ de la disent qu ils n'avaient
pas le choix qui aurait respecté cette
aberration babineau recond finale de
france serait une forme de désaveu après
la décision de non reconfirme en
d'emmanuel macron c'est la question
qu'on vous pose d'ailleurs sur le site
du figaro la question du jour
approuvez vous donc le choix exprimé par
jérôme salle au moment de ne par
confiner l'île de france et sur le site
vous êtes à 60 % à approuver alors que
sur twitter vous étiez 55% à ne pas
approuver jérôme salomon comme quoi les
rêves des gens qui sont pas
d'ile-de-france qui votent
effectivement ça sera une autre
association et selena guerre quoi ces
lignes et toi qui vois pas pourquoi
lorsqu'on va confie dans tous les cas
c'est vrai que c'était le sens de la
caisse l'une des questions qui étaient
posées tout à l'heure à l'assemblée
nationale par abba vision
député du monde qui est élu deux sets de
7 de cette région l'autre question du
jour et faut-il dissoudre l'unef c'est
une question qui est posée ce matin
après un tweet un tweet effacée par le
syndicat on va le on va le voir
on y voit notamment une photo avec le
nom de deux enseignants de lieux paix de
grenoble ils sont traités de fascistes
et d'islamophobe alors voyez vous voyez
le tweet de loin dont je vais vous le
décrire en haut à gauche juste au dessus
de là où il est et christian sport il y
a les noms de deux profs qui donc sont
traités de fascistes et d'islamophobe
une enquête est en cours pour injures
publiques
le syndicat a retiré le trip le tweet et
a parlé d' initiatives maladroites et
dangereuse voici ce qu'en pense marlène
schiappa et le garde des sceaux eric
dupond moretti
une fois le contexte compte le contexte
a une importance il ya à peine quelques
mois de cela tout monde a déploré le
fait qu'il y ait une décapitation d'un
professeur suite à des appels à la haine
sur les réseaux sociaux
je lance un appel à la responsabilité
notamment par rapport à l'unef je crois
que vous avez raison de le rappeler
l'unef a une responsabilité on ne peut
pas relayé des appels à la haine et des
choses aussi graves
ce qu'il faut dix ans dans les nappes
d'abord si vous le voulez bien
on va rappeler que dans notre beau pays
de liberté on peut caricaturer on peut
ne pas aimer une religion on peut
vouloir quand on est enseignant
organiser un débat autour d'une religion
et si on n'est pas content quand on est
étudiant il ya des recours si ce qui est
dit par l'enseignant est constitutif
d'une infraction pénale il saisit le
procureur de la république
on va revenir sur ce que l'on dit ces
enseignants mais d'abord béatrice cet
après midi les syndicats
en tout cas l'union syndicale qui le
premier syndicat à sciences po grenoble
a fait donc une conférence de presse ce
matin et a dit cette polémique a été
instrumentalisée afin de nourrir le
discours sur l'islam au gauchisme
concept qui n'existe pas selon le cnrs
contrairement à l'islamophobie
ces attaques médiatiques n'ont qu'un
seul effet occulter les problèmes de
fond à savoir les déclarations sur les
personnes musulmanes et leur
stigmatisation est ce que c'est votre
point de vue non c'est clairement pas
mon point de vue c'est en fait une
scission de l'unef studio syndicale qui
existe à grenoble c'est une façon de
seuil et de retourner l'arroseur arrosé
voilà c'est nous qui avons fait la
boulette mais vous il est manipulé par
les autres pour pouvoir justifier ça il
aurait voulu donner raison à frédéric
vidal il n'est pas autre chose que ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est voilà c'est c'est
vraiment d'une c'est d'une bêtise grave
parce qu'il ya des bêtises qu'ils sont
sans conséquences mais là c'est une
bêtise grave et qui traduit un climat
qui montre que l'unef qui n'est plus le
premier syndicat des étudiants ce qui
fut longtemps ce qu'il n'est plus je
crois depuis 2016 c'est la fage et qui
est en perte de vitesse mais alors dans
des proportions phénoménales et qui
essaye de s'accrocher de récupérer les
étudiants musulmans qui eux peuvent être
mieux organisé plus mobilisés et pour
essayer de gonfler un peu les jets à
dire les troupes
il sauvait une vice-présidente voilée
kikizo canton enfin bon moi je suis très
âgés mais quand je me souviens des ddd
combat de deux d'une f
c'est qui était un combat pour la
laïcité pour le féminisme pour l'égalité
finissez atterrante
c'est vraiment un terran et est vraiment
très très très préoccupant et sur l'idée
de la dissolution
je dis non parce que si vous voulez
mobiliser les étudiants et communes fo
retrouve du monde derrière elle sait
exactement ce qu'il faut faire alors
surtout pas mais c'est intéressant ce
que là on a la démonstration en vraie
grandeur virelles
de la réalité de l'islamo gauchisme
c'est très exactement cela l'islamo
gauchisme
ce sont des gauchistes ce qu est l unef
qui était un syndicat de gauche et
encore il est nu mais voilà mais d'une
gauche universaliste laïque républicaine
eux ali c'était ça l'unef
ça a toujours été ça et qui étant de
gauche va dériver
c'est pas l'islamo gauchisme c'est pas
des islamistes les islamo gauchistes et
des gens de gauche qui vont soit par
calcul soit par aveuglement embrasser la
cause d'abord des musulmans et pour
finir des islamistes c'est très
exactement ce qui se passe un syndicat
qui autrefois était un syndicat de
gauche classique alors il y avait ceux
qui étaient les plus à gauche c'est un
peu extrême gauche puis avait les clans
ps tous à se tirer tirer dessus il y
avait ceux de la lcr qui venait de
l'accuser de l'entreprise moi je viens
de l'époque où il y avait les amis de
cambadélis tout ça c'est des salles le
l'unef mais c'était l'amateurisme de au
fond du parti socialiste après ces
gauches les gauchistes de l'unef
devenait d'onet député social au net de
l'important député socialiste je ne
prends pas du jugement de valeur donc
eux et donc ce syndicat est en train de
devenir c'est la démonstration absolu de
la réalité de l'islamo gauchisme
larnaudie ça n'existe pas mais wade à
prendre mais je me rappelle d'ailleurs
c'est amusant il ya pas si longtemps il
ya deux ans c'était on disait dans la
théorie du genre ça n'existe pas il n'y
a pas de théorie du genre mais ne croyez
pas du tout ça y'a pas de tout genre
évidemment que d une antenne relais pour
nous reconnaître côté sexe l'islamo
gauchisme ça existe alors si on est
pourrait alors il faut dire oui nous
considérons que les musulmans sont
systématiquement opprimés dans ce pays
sont victimes d'un racisme systémique se
sont l'un vaudois nationale a admis
sinon on est content
à ce moment là il fallait qu'ils
appellent ça puisque cd dans une semaine
sur le thème de l'égalité 1 c'était des
débats qui devaient être organisés ils
avaient qu'à parler de racisme anti
musulman
s'ils voulaient et pas d'islamophobie
mais ce qui est plus intéressant c'est
que ce qui s'est passé avant c'est à
dire ça ces déclarations c'est ce qui
s'est passé avant dans le cours d'un des
enseignant à sciences po qui est un
professeur d'allemand je crois et qui
est fait pour quelle raison je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas si c'est directement
lié à cette semaine ou pas c'est sans
doute le cas a demandé à ce que tous les
membres de ce syndicat l'union syndicale
sorte de son corps à niamey les deux
professeurs effectivement c'est un
maître de conférences qui avaient un
cours optionnels qui est un professeur
de géopolitique justement et qui a fait
un cours sur les musulmans dans le monde
rit est effectivement qui était qui
était contestée par ce syndicat par
l'union syndicale est un moment de
guerre lasse il a dit mais si vous ne
faites pas partie de ce coup on n'est
pas la peine de venir à ce cours là et
je vous demande de partir ça c'est un
pote professeurs et puis il y avait un
professeur d'allemand qui effectivement
lui a dans cette locale de cette semaine
sur l'islamophobie a contesté le concept
de main sur l'égalité et et contre les
contre le racisme et l'islamophobie et
il a contre le racisme l'antisémitisme
et l'islamophobie et il a contesté le
fait que le terme d'islamophobie soit
sourire il a derrière antisémites et il
avait raison et je vous propose de
l'écouter parce que peut-être que le
problème dépasse le cadre même de
syndicats étudiants majorité des
enseignants chercheurs n'a pas le
courage de dire que je le suis un
démocrate que je ils n'arrivent pas hier
ils ont discuté trois heures ils ont
déchiré il y en avait peut-être qu'ils
n'ont rien dit il ya deux qui m'ont
défendue
2 il ya une majorité de mes collègues
qui m'a est maintenant parce qu'en plus
je traîne à leurs yeux
l'établissement dans la boue alors que
c'est moi qui risque ma peau en fait
les deux professeurs à lui ils sont sous
protection
je vous disiez il a raison c'est sûr
qu'il a raison et si vous voulez je
pense que c'est aussi des tensions qui
sont avec le département d'histoire où
il ya une maîtresse de conférences
d'histoire qui est sûre cette logique au
fond de l'islamophobie et qui dénonce
est bon je le dis avec tristesse mais
sans lâcheté à la différence d'un
certain nombre d'enseignants il ya une
certaine lâcheté à dire aujourd'hui
qu'il faut savoir dire dont savoir
s'opposer bon les instances dirigeantes
de l'université semble le faire de
sciences po mais le laboratoire de
recherche auquel appartient cet
enseignant qui vient de parler a pris la
défense du groupe contre lui quand il
dit on en a eu que deux pour me soutenir
il dit sans doute quelque chose de très
très juste et pour ma part je trouve ça
extrêmement grave c'est le moment où on
ne doit pas céder à ces à ces pratiques
et il avait raison l'enseignant de dire
on ne dit pas y islamophobie l'avait
khadir racisme anti musulman puisqu'on
était sur les questions de rendre un
antisémitisme anticipe musulmans ça se
justifierait exactement ce que disait
madame vide alors elle sans doute eu
tort qu'elle était maladroite en donnant
une clique comme fait faire une mission
de dents de scie ne renoncez pas la
mission qui toute façon est déjà
tellement là dedans qui n'aurait rien
trouvé
enfin bon bref mais quand elle disait
qu'il y avait un entrisme que ces
idées-là s'infiltrer dans l'université
et partant de militants purs et durs
contaminé il faut pas dire ça veut dire
qu'en grain et faute est contaminé c'est
des métaphores horrible mais c'est bien
ça qu'on voit c'est à dire des des
enseignants qui sont sans doute pas
eux-mêmes gauchiste ni islamo gauchistes
qui petit à petit par peur pour pas
avoir d'ennuis pour pas pour pas faire
de vagues vont dire au prof d'allemand
non exagère laisse tomber à tahiti a été
un peu fort parce que c'est comme ça a
été un peu fort
c'est ce que disait madame vidal la
véraison de ce point de vue là et il ya
donc à moi j'ai toute une jeune
génération d'étudiants d'enseignants
chercheurs qui ont été formés dans cette
matrice intersectionnelle aux études de
genre aux études des colonials aux
études de mes ennuis ont peut être fort
mais ça moi j'ai aimé c'est nier
beaucoup mais quand on gagne c'est quand
on voit enfin c'est presque on ne
produit que ça il est normal de parler
de la pollution et de la dépression peut
râler mais comment le seul prisme dan
est la même en 2006 devient la
domination des colonies alors j ai tous
les acteurs sur ses draps blancs sur les
noirs des hommes sur les haut et court
dans la violence n'est pas ça qui se
passe bancs de l'université puisque j'y
vais encore quand même de temps en temps
on peut pas dire que c'est ça qui est
exclusif dans l'université c'est parce
que ce serait pas mes mails avaient
jeûné un petit groupe evans qui soit
suffisamment mobilisateur mobilisés et
qui se sent c'est tout seul vous verrez
jamais personne il va jamais débattre
avec vous c'est parce qu'ils sont en
groupe et qu'ils se sentent un peu plus
rassurés parce qu'en groupes qui vont
pouvoir faire du bruit venir perturber
votre dos de chocobo
oui bah on a toujours connu ça hein si
vous voulez ça mais c'est vrai une chose
quand même parce que la classe politique
dans son ensemble a vraiment critiqué à
juste titre ce qui s'était passé sauf la
france insoumise quand même
et parce que je pense que je pense que
l'unef qui était comme vous des à viviez
socialiste est plutôt que pour les ans
et à vue vient pour pour les impôts les
a soumis aujourd'hui
et regardez il avait été même jusqu'à
mettre une candidate c'était du côté du
dans le vaucluse qui était aussi mal et
qui avait fait du bruit était quand même
c'était la x et oui anti catholique mais
bien sûr donc il était anti religieux
et maintenant ils donnent ils pas il en
soit cet univers sûr mais ça veut dire
aussi pourquoi sa dérive parce qu'ils
n'ont plus du tout j'allais dire de
matrice politique d'une idéologie
construite sur le alors il pourrait
toujours s'occuper du bien-être de la
vie des étudiants et je sais qu'ils
auraient un qui aurait de quoi faire bon
mais ceux qui font relativement peu
exactement ils ont joué ensemble
je crains tic enfin ils ont une matrice
ils sont partis ils sont passés de
néologie telle marque si non mais c'est
pas la seule exploitation de l'homme par
l'homme et tout ça à ils sont passés de
l'exploitation la domination et donc
c'est une matrice et une vision du monde
donc les hommes dominent les femmes les
blanc dominent les noirs les
colonisateurs dominent les colonisés et
ils vont tout expliqué en font que ça
c'est une idéologie constitue pour la
pac
je pense que d'abord avant d'être une
idéologie à laquelle il adhère c'était
récupérer des troupes dans ces c'est
devenu aujourd'hui colis à moins de 5%
des étudiants qui votent aux élections
bc devient ça devient avait sa grille
d'analysé je suis allé en train de
remplacer le marxisme c'est une sorte de
néo marxistes ou les halles est
différent où le lexique à l'époque du
maxxis y avait beaucoup plus d'étudiants
syndiqués il y en a aujourd'hui vous
regardez les lieux de vie qu'on les
brûle un compte qu'on était publié je
crois que commandité par la licra où on
voit que dans les collèges
le recul des idées de l'elysée ça prouve
que dans les esprits et tetra de
s'imprimer cette matrice là je le
regrette absolument ça progresse et chez
les jeunes générations chez les jeunes
duration de chez les étudiants et chez
les jeunes profs alors j'ai de plus en
plus les jeunes ont commencé à fabriquer
des étudiants à cette matrice haletant
parmi eux
non mais tant mieux si c'est le cas
dissoudre l'unef non nous dit ce
syndicaliste porter plainte oui ce fait
divers témoigne de la perte de repères
idéologiques
alors justement on n'a pas entendu votre
objection justement par rapport à ce que
disait alexis sur le fait qu' il ya une
survivance en tous les cas un variant
néo marxiste comme toujours à l'oeuvre
jeu petit 74 me dit c'est aussi la même
chose chez les parents d'élèves avec la
fcpe également effectivement il ya eu
des 0 il ya une vraie évolution a fermé
mais on peut pas de menace ça ne passe
pas sans bruit à la fcpe
voilà c'est pas parce que vous avez un
dirigeant qui dit ça que n'y ait pas de
débat à la fcpe
marre de payer pour ces associations qui
ne veulent que détruire notre pays nous
dit thomas sur youtube et effectivement
c'est une question qui était posée sur
twitter faut-il continuer de
subventionner l'unef et vous êtes une
majorité de non à répondre plus de 70 %
et un internaute qui nous dit des profs
sous protection c'est accepter dans
notre société
la présence d'extrémistes et on rappelle
effectivement que ces deux professeurs
sont sous protection c'est ce qu'a
annoncé hier gérald darmanin c'est déjà
arrivé un des professeurs sous
protection
non mais c'est vrai que pendant la
guerre d'algérie j'ai très bien protégé
mais après c'est vrai qu'il faut
sanctionner il faut les individus moi je
ne suis pas pour la suite on va pas
supprimer l'unef
il faut des motifs juridiques que je
pense qu'on n'en avait déjà pas beaucoup
pour génération identité en fait cette
poussette vous prie de supprimer des
accusations la liberté d'expression ça
existe les gens doivent penser dès juin
et en revanche quelqu'un qui commet un
délit qui est de mettre en danger la vie
d'autrui en inscrivant son nom émetteurs
islamophobe
celui là il doit être puni il doit être
viré de l'université sur la voilà ça il
faut prendre d'exception et puis il faut
imposer dans les universités la
possibilité de débattre de tout ça n'en
est pas et pas j'allais dire baisser la
garde mais m'est imposé y revenir et
mais j'ai à dire construire l'amphi pour
que ce petit groupe bull ne perturbe pas
tout et conduisent les bains vrai que de
sciences po à paris ou à bordeaux à
lille où on le nom
confer de confiance dont étaient
interdites sylviane agacinski qui est
pas la bordure de à bordeaux figure de
la réaction garder quand même sont
exagérées google chrome os voilà enfin
bon on se rend compte que c'est à dire
que vous dites vous avez sûrement raison
quand vous dites que c'est pas
majoritaire chez les étudiants avec vous
mais mais c'est ce sont des des
mouvements de pensée qui sont
suffisamment puissants pour faire régner
une perte de terrain
ça vous semble être une grande vanité
mais au tout début d'hérodote quand
j'allais présenter la revue avec lacoste
dans les universités a lille on a été
interdit d'expression il a revu a été
brûlé et on était en 1975 alors la
dernière dernières parutions par baur
confie la dernière parution de la revue
hérodote
c'est consacrée à l'afrique médiane qui
est le centre de du continent africain
et vous pouvez le retrouver
dépêchez-vous puisque le prochain numéro
va arriver ce sera jeudi et il sera
consacré au miles 20 au maghreb et donc
en librairie le 20 mars
peut-être pour terminer ce témoignage
que cité par notre confrère paul sujet
sur cette histoire
donc dans cette affaire a grenoble c'est
un ancien de l'unef qui qui s'exprime
cette histoire m'a immédiatement fait
penser à samuel pâtit là on lui met
clairement une cible dans le dos il n'a
jamais obtenu le moindre propos c'était
à propos d'un des profs islamophobe
seulement les élèves n'étaient pas
d'accord avec lui il cela leur est
insupportable
il faut savoir dans cet établissement si
vous êtes à la droite de benoît hamon
vous êtes déjà un fasciste le climat
s'est dégradé ces dernières années avant
les attentats on pouvait davantage
discuter alors on peut continuer à
discuter en tous les cas sur le web et
sur point de vue merci beaucoup de nous
avoir ce soir et on se retrouve demain
même heure même endroit avec guillon
enquête
[Musique]